hey guys Pete here today I'll be doing a
better call Saul season 5 episode 9
preview video I will break down the
official season 5 episode 9 trailer
scene-by-scene
and talk about the episode 9 sneak peak
clip that AMC has released we're almost
at the end of this great season just two
episodes left and I gotta say there's a
lot of different things swirling around
our man Jimmy McGill first a quick
spoiler warning this video will contain
spoilers about everything that's
happened and better call Saul and
Breaking Bad up into this point I'll be
speculating on the final two episodes of
the season based on everything that's
out there in the media so if you're not
into that kind of thing this video won't
be for you episode 9 is titled bad
choice road it's written and directed by
Thomas schnozz who is a longtime
contributor to BCS and Breaking Bad his
resume is too detailed to list here but
a cool piece of trivia is that he wrote
and directed episode 507 of Breaking Bad
say my name which is essentially the end
of Mike Armentrout story so we know this
is in good hands the better call Saul
5:09 episode description reads in the
wake of Jimmy's traumatic misadventure
Kim takes stock of what is important
jimmy attempts to return to business as
usual but it's more difficult than
anticipated Gus and Mike set a plan in
motion the trend in this series has been
for some big event to happen in the
penultimate episode to set up the finale
Chuck hitting his head in the copy store
in season 2 Kim getting into her car
accident in three and Jimmy getting
rejected at his license reinstatement
while at the same time Werner leaves the
warehouse to try and rendezvous with his
wife there's a thing that happens that
sets up the ending in season five we've
just reached the point where both sides
of the story have come back together and
it's not clear what parts of it will be
concluded before the final season begins
let's take a look at the scenes in the
trailer first because there's a lot from
those that we can actually speculate on
the trailer opens with the shot of a
highway travel center something like a
convenience store or a truck stop my
consol are looking worn from their trip
through the desert there may be some
significance to this place but I don't
recognize it by the sign out front we
could see they bought some new clothes
got hydrated and cleaned up but they are
sunburnt and looked like they've been
through hell that's followed by Jimmy
walking into the cashier at the
courthouse with the duffel bags full of
money he looks like he went straight
there as he's still wearing the clothes
he bought at the store on the highway in
this shot we see him put the bags up on
the counter while the woman behind it
looks at him in the $7,000,000 sneak
peek video we hear more of the dialogue
Jimmy walks up and knocks on the glass
saying the Guzman Jorge she goes to the
computer and looks it up and then with
the shocked look on her face she asks 7
million dollars he replies yep and then
he puts the bags on the counter while
she looks on in this clip we also get a
closer look at his t-shirt and can make
out that it says these colors ain't
running in the main trailer that cuts to
a shot of nacho on the phone he says
that's it right he's done and we see him
pull up outside the courthouse in this
car we imagine he's talking to Jimmy
Jimmy's telling him the bail is posted
and now he's coming to pick him up as
we're looking at his car we see only two
episodes left this season flash on the
screen which is really sad this show has
been helping me get through these crazy
times and I'm really kind of bummed that
it's coming to an end after that we get
a shot of a money counting machine in
action inside the cashiers office
they're counting and stacking the money
on a desk
it all looks pretty absurd but I can't
think of a reason that it wouldn't go
down like this if a judge issued someone
a large cash only bond we see the
prosecuting attorneys from the DA's
office watching through the windows at
the counter the woman who we saw in
court opposite Jimmy pauses and turns to
look at him and he's sitting in a chair
there waiting her look tells us that
she's suspicious about the origin of the
money Jimmy who looks crazy with his
sunburn and convenience store t-shirt
just raises his eyebrows without saying
a word
next we watch as Jimmy who's now wearing
a suit comes out of a courtroom a DA
bill Oakley who's a recurring character
says hey that was something what
happened in there
not familiar with how posting bail and
getting a client released in this
situation would work because I've never
had to do it it seems like you would
just go and pay and then the prisoner
would be released and there would be no
reason to appear in front of a judge so
I don't know what's going on here but as
the trailer continues we hear a DA bill
say you'll probably have to change your
name again in the voiceover there's a
quick shot of Mike sitting in his car
not much context to go with but it is
during the day so this isn't happening
at the same time as the scene when we
saw nacho pull up earlier it looks like
maybe he's sighs or he looks unhappy
about whatever it is he's watching after
that we watch this Jimmy walks down a
hallway in the courthouse looking back
as he goes he's wearing the same suit E
as on when Bill approaches him and he
definitely looks concerned here that
cuts to his shot at Kim standing in
front of the desk in Richards office at
Schweikart and Cokely we see them
through the window and can't make her
out but he has a serious look on his
face there's a shot of Gus sitting at
his desk looking up at someone could be
just about anyone this could be Mike
returning from the desert to tell him
what happened this could be Lalo we
really don't know after that we see
Jimmy coming through a door probably
tied right to that scene where we saw
him walking down the hall he looks
relieved to be out of the hallway but
worried and stressed out about
whatever's going on the trailer ends
with the shot of nachos car driving down
a dirt road he has someone in the
passenger seat which would probably be
Lalo there in the desert which looks
like the area where he sent Jimmy to
pick up the money but it's shot in a way
that we can't tell what's going on we
just know that nachos driving with
someone down a dirt road in the desert
Jimmy dropping off 7 million dollars in
cash seems to have raised his profile
the story would probably spread through
the legal community in the courthouse
and just keep going this is a murder
case so it may have some attention
already and we can see by the way it
looks as they're counting this money
where else would this money have come
from who has 7 million dollars in cash
laying around this didn't come from the
bank it looks suspicious there may be
immediate complications but I'm no
expert on how that process
works I don't know how rare it is for
the criminal attorney to pay a cash bond
and so on from the episode description
and the trailer it looks like it's gonna
cause Jimmy problems going forward it
might also cause problems for Kim by
association which might be why she's in
Rich's office at the same time there's
no clues as to when this is happening
there isn't enough in this clip to show
where Kim's career side of things is
headed before the end of the season
after the last episode her being known
to Lalo became the main thing on our
what is going to happen to Kim radar but
she might be up against some problems at
work as well the thing I'm most
interested to see as far as Kim and
Jimmy is concerned is whether he'll
still tell the truth he's gonna come
back from the desert a changed man but
is he gonna let that affect this setup
that he has with Kim I'm not sure what
kind of story he could concoct that
would make sense I mean I guess if you
think about it if he just broke down his
car died for good it would essentially
take him the same amount of time to get
back to town he still has to walk
through the desert there's still no cell
service there's no way for him to reach
out and get rescued he has to physically
walk through the desert at the same time
there's all these little loose ends that
would happen there she might say let's
go back and get your car so the right
thing for him to do would be to tell her
the truth but he wants to protect her at
the same time we definitely saw that
come out in the last episode that he's
frightened about the fact that he's
brought her into the game he's gonna
learn about her seeing Lalo and that's
gonna make things even worse as far as
nacho is concerned I've been on the mind
that Gus's plan was to get Lalo out
because he figures that he would be
forced to flee to Mexico and that's
better all the way around for him he can
kill him there without suspicion he
doesn't have to worry about him
physically showing up and it seems like
Lalo probably won't do that nothing
about this character is predictable and
I'm wondering if he's going to make it
out of this season alive originally I
thought for sure he's such a good
opponent for Gus he really steps up that
rivalry but I mean something's got to
come to the head at the end of the
season at the same time and the fact
that this is a third unknown entity that
did the attack on Saul I think
everything kind of depends on who that
was we know that they got tipped off by
the guy at the Salamanca warehouse they
could be related to the Espinoza's the
group that we saw the cousins take out
last season before they fled back south
of the border or they could be somebody
brand new either way they could end up
stepping into the role of putting
pressure on the cartel side of things
the other thing to consider is that we
have a couple year time-jump coming up
at some point so it's really hard to see
whether they're gonna leave everything
at the end of the season with Kim's you
might just make it through to the next
season
she might not leave she might not break
up with Jimmy you might not disappear or
get killed or whatever's gonna happen
same thing with Lalo but I have a
feeling that one of those two stories is
going to reach a conclusion and if it's
not that then I feel like something has
to happen to notch it one way or the
other
it says Gus and Mike set a plan in
motion in the episode description and I
think that completely hinges on what
Lalo does so I don't know what to say
about that until we see where things go
it also says that Kim takes stock of
what is important which is just vague
enough not to really say anything what
happens with her is gonna hinge on
whether Jimmy tells her the truth I'm
leaning towards he will which will mean
that they'll be working together and we
know Kim is the kind of person who wants
to fix things so there's a lot of
problems that could arise from that
Jimmy will have to deal with Lalo also
and explain what happened and I'm
guessing that Mike will tell him what to
say as far as that's concerned I think
the fact that he made it with the money
and he gets him out will go a long way
as far as Lalo trusting him but the
situation is what it is and I don't
think Lalo is just going to flee the
country without finding out what's going
on so I'm gonna leave it there because
there's just so much stuff that could go
either way I can't wait for this episode
to see where things go let me know in
the comments what you think where you
think we're headed and how this season
is going to wrap up please like this
video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already
thanks for watching I will talk to you
soon